hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
welcome to the review of the tablet I
waited so long for the Nexus 9 this is
going to be a pretty brief review
because there isn't really that much
different or new about the Nexus 9
nothing spectacular about it it's
basically HTC's safest bet ever so the
Nexus 9 it's a 9 inch tablet it's
running stock Android 5.0 lollipop right
now and it's somewhere in between the
Nexus 10 from two years ago and the
Nexus 7 from last year so like I said
it's a 9 inch display with this sort of
a squarish 4 by 3 aspect ratio that all
the iPads have and it has the soft touch
back which is extremely similar to
actually what we saw in the Nexus 7 it's
not a fancy metal or anything just a
layer of thin plastic with a soft touch
coating on the back the bit of metal we
do get is on the sides which gives a
tablet these flat sides for better grip
ability it even makes one-handed use a
little easier for me but yeah it's a
thin chamfered ring of metal around the
edges where you can grip the tablet on
that's about it in terms of build
quality it does say the word Nexus on
the back filled in the same way it does
on the back of the phone the Nexus 6 and
the camera on the bag does protrude a
little bit but not enough to make it
rock on an even surface so it still lays
flat so that's fine the only really
noteworthy thing actually about the
hardware for me is the buttons which are
terrible they're awful buttons they're
really close to flush and super mushy
they're not clicky or tactile at all if
you close your eyes basically and try to
press the power button you wouldn't know
when you turned it on or not that's how
little click there is and if there is
any less travel it would literally be
inside the tablet it's ridiculous how
hard it is to press now HTC has
apparently noted that this is a problem
so if you order a nexus 9 today you'll
actually get a sort of a nexus 9 2.0
it's a revised hardware model with new
clicky err more tactile buttons so
that's good for people who are getting
it now but that's not solving my problem
but one thing that's nice is HTC is
built-in tapped awake so you can double
tap the display when it's off to wake it
up and that'll I guess help me avoid
using the crappy button just it's too
bad there's no double tap to sleep which
means I still have to use the button to
turn it off but
it's a step in the right direction
anyway the rest of the hardware is
totally fine
up front you have a nine inch display
with the 2048 by 1536 resolution again
the same as those iPads so that's
slightly larger display and pretty
average sized bezels make this tablet
like I said a bit larger than the Nexus
7 or the iPad Mini and the display is
pretty good I think it's one of the high
points of the tablet its resolution
makes it pretty sharp so it comes in at
over 280 pixels per inch there's very
little color shift it's really saturated
and certain overall really good looking
display viewing angles are nice so
overall I give a thumbs up to the panel
the only thing is it does have a bit of
a light leak problem from the backlight
so when it's dark out or when the lights
are off or you use this tablet at night
you will notice the uneven lighting and
we'll call it light bleeding in from the
sides around the edge of the tablet you
can only find this on really low quality
panels but I only really notice it again
when it's dark so it's the only con I
found to an otherwise very nice display
flanking the display are yes dual stereo
front-facing speakers these top off the
media experience of the Nexus 9 very
well and honestly they're not even that
great speakers again they're pretty
similar to the front-facing ones on the
Nvidia shield they're not spectacular
but simply placing them on the front
makes them so much better than the iPad
or the Nexus 7 speakers which are side
facing or rear facing so front facing
speakers are great they get loud enough
that you can hear from across the room
if you're into that it's not boom sound
or anything but I will gladly take it
also on the back you have an 8 megapixel
camera it's good for basically just
scanning barcodes it's not really a good
camera for anything past that it kind of
looks similar just looking at it to the
Nexus 5 but I don't see a lot of people
buying this tablet for the camera
quality so yeah it's it's there if you
need it but hopefully you don't need it
so yeah you can tell there's nothing
really all that incredible about the
hardware of the Nexus 9 here it's really
all about the software experience it's
running the latest version of Android
out the box and of course will continue
to be first in line for updates so when
Google releases them here we have
Android 5.0 lollipop as smooth as ever
on the 64-bit NVIDIA k1 chip with two
gigs of RAM actually
and a lot of what you find here is
really just the phone experience and
blown up to a larger display that can
also rotate landscape not sure if that's
a good or a bad thing that it's moving
towards that gradually but I guess it
seems like when we first started with
Android on tablets there were a lot more
tablets specific interface tweaks like
the notification bar on the left and the
quick settings on the right but I guess
for the sake of continuity it's slowly
moving back to a more simplified
interface that resembles a phone more
but I'd still like to see Android 5.0
take advantage of the larger display in
a few more places maybe I just need to
add more widgets or something I guess
since its Android I can do that either
way I really like Android 5.0 here and
pretty much all of the apps I use are
here so if you're coming from an iPad
that story might be a little bit
different but I'm a heavy Google service
user and this is great for me and again
performance here is really smooth
basically as smooth as or smoother than
any other Android tablet experience
except sometimes it likes to hang when
launching apps like on a blazing fast
64-bit tablet launching the YouTube app
it shouldn't hang that long it shouldn't
take that long to open up an app it
happened on occasion but particularly
when I'm multitasking a lot and a lot of
apps are dropping out of the 2 gigs of
ram but in the past it hasn't really
been a problem and everything else has
been as smooth as expected and in app
performance 2 is also really smooth it's
a great media tablet so I played a lot
of games I was smooth the entire time
there no dropped frames same deal with
web browsing in Chrome messing around
with other tablet optimized apps the
experience has always been very very
quick and very smooth so that's great
you also get all the latest and greatest
features so if Google comes out with
some fancy new features in Android that
roll out tomorrow people with a Nexus
device will be the first to get it I'll
leave a link to my review of Android 5.0
right below if you want to check that
out there's some good stuff in here
useful stuff like screen pinning
lockscreen notifications and material
design everywhere all these animations
it's all good stuff
and I happen to love it so yeah Nexus 9
it's a nice lightweight good performing
compact tablet running stock Android
because of its size it's like right on
the border between
and one handed and two handed use it
both are really okay it's also a bit of
a smaller battery just to note it's a
6700 milliamp hour battery so you'll
probably charge it every two or three
days instead of every five or six like
with the same usage on bigger tablets oh
and pro tip if you're choosing between
colors still I would go with the white
Nexus 9 and Nexus 6 because the black of
the same material is a serious
fingerprint magnet the white doesn't
really show fingerprints nearly as much
so at the end of the day I have some
very specific mixed feelings about the
Nexus 9 I think when a lot of us heard
that it was going to be made by HTC we
had these really high expectations for
the build quality the last notable thing
that HTC made was the One m8 and that
phone is known for its build quality and
beastly speakers so a lot of us were
expecting this new Nexus tablet to be
known for its build quality and beastly
speakers well it has decent speakers but
it's built exactly the same really as
the Nexus 7 was if you added metal sides
to it so it's not that special in terms
of build and a lot of people are going
to have that wake-up call when they
finally receive it so it should be
priced lower it's a $400 tablet right
now for the lowest end 16 gig Wi-Fi only
model in the Play Store and for that
price it's hard to recommend because it
essentially feels like a slightly larger
Nexus 7 and the Nexus 7 was really good
for the price it was known for how cheap
it was so you got to pick somewhere
between really well priced and really
premium and well built and right now
it's not striking that balance I think
this this is a better tablet to be sold
at $300 and I think sooner or later is
going to be sold for $300 maybe not in
the Play Store but it's kind of hard to
sell this tablet for 400 bucks also in
the Nvidia shield tablet is also out
there running lollipop with front-facing
speakers the NVIDIA k1 not quite the
same 64-bit chip but very similar specs
and a really nice build for 300 bucks
it's sitting out there cannibalizing
sales essentially competing with this
Nexus 9 so hard to recommend buying it
for 400 bucks but if you have to have a
Nexus tablet you have to have the stock
Android experience first is you don't
get a lollipop immediately on the shield
tablet then the software experience is
what you would buy this next
9 tablet 4 and that's what I would
recommend it for people who are buying
this tablet for the software experience
this is not a tablet to buy for the
hardware experience because it's not
that great it's not going to feel like
400 bucks even the iPad Mini retina is
completely made of metal and far
outclasses
all of the build quality of the other
tablets out there that are made of
plastic so I recommend taking a look at
the software experience if you want to
buy this tablet otherwise there are
other I review the Nvidia shield tablet
I'll leave the link to that right below
if you want to check that out too and
there are other options to consider but
you got to have a nexus you got to have
a nexus thanks for watching guys if you
enjoyed this video feel free to hit that
thumbs up button below and there are
more videos like this coming so be sure
to subscribe if you haven't already
again thanks and I'll talk to you guys
in the next one peace